[Music]  Hey where's your Snickers when I was 14  years old every day I used to stop here  at the 7-Eleven and steal a king-sized  Snicker bar because I couldn't afford to  buy ones that was my pre-workout food I  did that for almost a year every day I  had to come back and buy every Snickers  bar on those shelves what's your name  okay ring all these up  the kids like  [Music]  nice to steal the Snickers every day  we're doing that  I gotta come back and I have to private  you know what I mean you guys look look  listen I'm trying to count all this [ __ ]  I don't need to hear your stories go  tell Oprah what are you guys doing  it you're welcome here you got Big  Brother come on you want anything you  got anything  [Music]  [Music]  come on over here let's take a picture  [Music]